good afternoon welcome to the cato
institute my name is Brent Lindsay I'm
the director of Cato's Center for trade
policy studies and we're pleased today
to be hosting a book forum on the latest
effort by the dynamic duo of John Nichol
Thwaite and Adrian Wooldridge the book
is called the company the short history
of a revolutionary idea we're pleased to
have one of the authors Adrian
Wooldridge here with us today as well as
noted author Dan Jurgen who will be
commenting on the book now it may seem a
bit of a stretch for a trade policy shop
to be sponsoring an event about a book
that examines the centuries long history
of the limited liability joint stock
company but one of the wonderful things
about doing trade policy is you get to
get your tentacles into just about
everything environmental issues food
safety labor rights debates about
productivity growth and income
inequality telecom regulation financial
services regulation capital controls
privatization foreign policy cultural
issues and on and on and the fact is
that the ongoing raging debate about
globalization which provides the larger
context for trade policy in all its many
facets is to a significant extent a
debate about the nature and purpose of
the modern business corporation in
particular consider the fact that in the
global and the end the
anti-globalization movement the term
globalization is frequently preceded by
the epithet corporate they're not
anti-globalization the protesters tell
us they're simply anti corporate
globalization right here is a standard
caricature of so-called corporate
globalisation taken from the website of
a group with the ungainly name of corp
watch in the absence of a coherent
alternative the transnational
corporations carry on inexorably
increasingly flag less and stateless
they weave global webs of production
commerce culture and finance virtually
unopposed they expand invest and grow
concentrating evermore wealth in a
limited number of hands they work in
coalition to influence local national
and international institutions and laws
and together with the international
institutions such as the world trade
the World Bank in the International
Monetary Fund and increasingly the
United Nations they are molding an
international system in which they can
trade and invest even more freely a
world where they are less and less
accountable to the cultures communities
and nation-states in which they operate
underpinning this effort is not the
historical inevitability of an evolving
enlightened civilization but rather the
unavoidable reality of the overriding
corporate purpose the maximization of
profits so in this view the worldwide
process of market oriented reform and
resulting cross-border economic
integration really boils down to a plot
by corporate elites and their puppets in
the multilateral institutions to profit
at the expense of the world's poor this
vision rests on a zero-sum understanding
of power if somebody loses or gives up
power it must be that somebody else has
gained in power commensurately in
particular since national governments
have to some extent at least curtailed
their power to control economic
decision-making it must be that
corporations have taken up the slack and
are now more powerful than ever before
demolishing this canard is one of the
many accomplishments of the company a
lucid entertaining and thoroughly
splendid little book to give us this
topical punchline and the story that
leads up to it I'll be turning the
podium over now to Adrian Wooldridge
adrian is the washington correspondent
of The Economist magazine which is quite
simply the best news magazine in the
world he is he is the co-author with
John Nichols weight of two previous
books the witch doctors making sense of
the management gurus and a future
perfect the challenge and hidden promise
of globalization
I must confess I haven't read witch
doctors but I have read the future
perfect and let me say it's one of the
very best books on globalization out
there at the very least is one of the
three best books on globalization
written by people on this stage
adrian has written for many other
publications besides the economist and
he was educated at Balliol College in
all souls College Oxford where he
received a Doctor of Philosophy degree
ladies and gentleman please join me in
welcoming Adrian Wooldridge
thank you very much bring for that very
kind introduction in my very brief
history of talking about this subject
I've encountered two very predictable
responses the first is a response from
the business community which is to say
yes whenever I say companies are
marvelous wonderful wealth creating
things the other is the response from
the anti-globalization left who
denounced this is absolute nonsense and
I'm actually very intrigued to see the
sort of response I'm going to get from
the Cato Institute because on the one
hand I would imagine people from the
Cato Institute would have nothing in
common with the anti-globalization
people but on the other hand there's a
very long and distinguished history of
libertarian hostility to corporations
and indeed some of the best critiques of
corporations are written by a V dicey a
great liberal thinker in the late 19th
century who thought thought that their
real instruments of collectivism and
ways of imposing the burden of fail of
business failure not on the people who
engage in business but on society as a
whole so I expect a slightly less
stereotyped response name perhaps
received in the past Hegel argued that
the foundation stone of modern societies
the state Marx argued that it was the
commune Hitler Lenin and the late Saddam
Hussein argued that it was the political
party before that a succession of state
Saints and sages are claimed the same
sort of thing for the parish church or
the feudal manner or the monarchy it's
the the central contention of this short
book that I've just co-written that
they're all wrong the foundation stone
of modern society is actually the
corporation the company the company is
really what's made us wealthy and the
company is also the foundation stone of
all of our way of life apart from the
family it's the single most important
institution in most people's lives
it was the company in the form of the
Massachusetts Bay Company in the
Virginia company that founded what we
British still refer to as the colonists
or some of us do
it was the company in the form of the
East India Company that created modern
India and it was the company in the form
of Standard Oil American steel and many
others that was responsible for turning
the United States from a sort of
collection of rural communities into a
modern integrated nation state these are
really revolutionary organizations why
they say revolutionary the obvious
reason is that they have dramatically
improved productivity and showered the
world than the material abundance but I
think there's also a more subtle answer
than that than that and that is that
companies have all or most of the legal
rights of individual human beings
without the attendant biological
disadvantages they're not condemned to
die of old age they can create offspring
pretty much at will and they can take on
many national identities whatever they
want as one great 18th century sage said
the trouble with corporations is that
they have neither souls to condemn nor
asses to kick and I think that's a
pretty frightening thing in the next 20
minutes or so I want to take you on a
quick tour through the history of the
company and also because this is the
Cato Institute use that history to look
to the future and see where we're going
to go in the next few years but I draw
your attention before I start this to
two forces which I think have shaped the
history of the company and the future of
the company the first is economic logic
and the second is political will
political arguments and I think these
two things interestingly quite often
pull in very very different directions
they're essentially two ways to define a
company the first is any organization
that's engaged in business and that can
include anything from informal Assyrian
trading arrangements to modern venture
partnerships the second is more specific
and that is the limited liability
publicly traded joint stock company up
until the middle of the 19th century you
could not get the privilege of limited
liability unless you've got a charter
from the government and unless you
agreed to do some very specific job with
which which had the the sanction of the
government and the big revolution of the
mid 19th century and I think in many
ways the big revolution that created the
modern world is that it becomes
relatively easy to set up limited
liability companies
the first companies in the broadest
sense of the world of the word go back
to about 3000 BC and people writing
contracts to trade to transport things
and to trade things up and down the
Euphrates River in Mesopotamia jump
forward to the Assyrians in 2000 BC and
you see a group that one normally
associates with biblical savagery
actually creating some fairly
sophisticated contracts one of the
oldest business contract still in
existence is 4000 years old and includes
a merchant called Ishtar who essentially
creates what might be almost like a
modern venture capital fund with a group
of other merchants putting a certain
number of pieces of silver the fund
lasts for four years and people get
profits in accordance with how many
pieces of silver they put in how much
work they put into it the grandparents
of the modern company I think can be
found in the early Middle Ages and two
sorts of organizations the first is the
Campania of northern Italy and these are
essentially partnerships rather fluid
and fragile partnerships and what makes
these these these partnerships so
difficult for the people involved in
them is the principle of unlimited
liability if you lose money you lose
everything and that everything meant
your freedom quite often you could be
put into prison or you could put into
servitude as a result of going bankrupt
and that meant that you had to trust the
people you're working with and you tend
to work with your closest relations and
the term company comes from two Latin
words Campanas meaning breaking bread
together so the whole element of trust
is absolutely vital to the company the
other grandparent is a rather sturdy
affair and those are the corporate
bodies of northern Italy of northern
Europe and these corporations relied
essentially on charters or monopolies
from the government and they included
everything from towns Gil's Oxford and
Cambridge colleges universities
monasteries and also business
enterprises and they actually tended to
be very enduring because they had this
pact with the government and the
corporation of London for example which
dates back to the 12th century still
owns about a quarter of the land in more
in the modern city of London so what you
essentially needed was something that
could bring together these two ideas the
one
the idea of the corporation with a
certain degree of sturdiness and
permanence and the other I'd the idea of
the trading empire and you actually got
this happening in the in the 16th
century with the rise of chartered
companies and I think these charted
companies are some of the most
extraordinary bizarre organizations
humanity has ever produced there was
sort of a cross between private sector
organizations and public sector
organizations they had monopolist from
the state they were used by the state as
instruments of imperialism essentially
instruments of state policy but they're
also private sector organizations in the
sense they had shareholders who drew
profits from their activities so
peculiar a peculiar mixed of two things
there were many many remarkable
chartered companies in both the good and
the bad sense of the word remarkable you
have the Virginia and Massachusetts
companies which in many ways not only
helped to found the United States but
also help to bring the notion of
democracy to the United States because
they're based on the principle that all
shareholders in the company have a right
to help determine the company's strategy
its policy and eventually the
shareholders become transmuted into
citizens and those citizens expect to
have a vote in the way that the the
Commonwealth's affairs are conducted the
bad side of the company was the north it
was the Royal Africa Company which
pioneered the the slave trade
essentially in which and which branded
its corporate logo RAC
into the flesh of its human subjects but
the most remarkable of all of these
companies was the East India Company and
it is absolutely extraordinary
organization first of all it seized
control of India it ran a whole
subcontinent it had an army of 260,000
people which is actually rather more
than the British Army at the time it had
a head office at 350 people in London it
helped to inspire the notion of company
mad I think Dilbert had been wandering
around company house in in in London
would not have been very surprised some
of the most the some of the slackers
shall I say were people who are writing
books on the side John Stuart Mill a
great company man said he found his
office duties and actual rest from other
mental occupations which I have carried
on simultaneously with them all three
people I'm here might have done a little
of their work
in their office hours tomislav peacock
wrote a poem from 10:00 to 11:00 at a
breakfast for seven from 11:00 till noon
to begin twist too soon from 12:00 to
1:00 asked what's to be done from 1:00
to 2:00 found nothing to do from 2:00 to
3:00 began to foresee that from 3:00 to
4:00 would be a damn ball who could
object to an organization that provided
a comfortable rest home for philosophers
and poets well actually most progressive
opinion in the 18th century condemned
the East India Company because the East
India Company was always going cap in
hand to government for more subsidies
and it was always despoiling the Indian
subcontinent the people who came back
from India who worked for the company
with regard to to save vulgar and
ostentatious they actually coined a new
word for them which was nabobs or nobs
and the result of this rather
ostentatious institution was that two
hundred and fifty years before that
anybody had ever heard of Naomi Klein
and the anti-globalization movement you
found some pretty surprising people who
had claiming that corporate capitalism
was an appalling thing Adam Smith for
example objected to the very idea of
joint coastal companies and he claimed
that they had universally proved either
burdensome or useless and it either
mismanaged or confined trade and he
didn't just object to the fact that
these were monopolies he also objected
to the to the problem the idea that
there was a split between ownership and
control because he thought that hired
managers would never bring the same sort
of anxious vigilance to the management
of a company that owner owner managers
would say he said that profusion and
negligence would always prevail with the
new corporate form a lot of support here
and and business people seem to agree
with that you find that the great
Industrial Revolution was essentially
powered by business partnerships by
family firms family firms can actually
find the money that they needed by
tap-tapping family but by tapping
relatives partnerships also seize
control of the slave trade the slave
trade in this period passes from the
role africa company to a bunch of slave
owning families and the corporation
seems to be used mainly for utilities
for running harbors and things like that
still I'm sure I'm gonna get objections
here but I think that that doesn't mean
that economic logic is necessarily on
the side of partnerships partnerships do
have this problem of unlimited liability
they have the pot the problem they're
very fragile creations they have the
problem the death of a partner the death
of a successor of an heir can lead to
very dramatic results if you recall
Charles Dickens his great novel Dombey
and son all the problems in that come
from the fact that Dom that the Dombey
son actually dies Dom be in his grief
hands over the running of the company to
his partner James kharka who then as
many partners seem to do runs off with
his wife robs the company of all its
money and destroys the organization said
partnerships are very fragile
organizations so business people really
struck stuck with the partnership firm
form of organization because they didn't
want to bring the state into into their
lives getting an act of Parliament in
Britain or a legislative act in in in
the United States could cost hundreds
and hundreds of dollars it was a very
expensive thing as a time-consuming
thing and if you got something from the
government you couldn't be guaranteed
that would honor its contracts the first
corporation in the United States was
something called the New London Society
for trade and commerce the Connecticut
legislature granted it a corporate
charter in May of 1732 and nine months
later it unilaterally simply withdrew
the Charter it changed the rules of the
game so this this was something that
people were put off doing rather than
something they didn't want to do and I
think two things dramatically changed
this situation the first is the rise of
an industry which needs very very large
quantities of capital and the first is
the decision by the government to get
out of the business of running companies
I want to jump forward to an evening in
the theater on October the 7th 1893
Gilbert and Sullivan who were the Andrew
Lloyd Webber of their age unveiled their
latest operetta it was called utopia
limited and it made fun of the latest
Victorian craze which the
limited-liability joint-stock company it
features an English company promoter
named mr. Gould Bree who arrives in a
South Sea Isle Island called utopia he
immediately turns all the citizens of
utopia into limited liability companies
even babies issue company
spectacies at one point these utopians
join together in singing what is perhaps
the most bizarre chorus ever set to
music in an operetta
all hail astonishing fact all hail
invention new the joint stock companies
act the act of 62 and utopia limited is
basically a celebration of a quirky
Victorian invention that had changed the
world the companies that were set free
by the act of 62 rapidly changed change
changed the universe they don't have to
go cap in hand to get so the government
whenever they want to to set up business
they can just set up business very
easily and these these companies and the
companies that are created in other
European countries in the United States
and imitation of this British act
turbocharged the first great a great age
of globalization they lure millions of
people from the from the land into the
cities they create these these these
huge urban centers with skyscrapers of
their Center they changed the way people
work and play and the year the year
after I think that the the curtain went
up on the on the Optus operator their
high o Supreme Court ruled the Standard
Oil had created a monopoly it saw that
peril was shifting from the government
to these great monopolies
how on earth did this happened how had
we gone from a world in which companies
corporations were marginal perhaps
doomed entities into one in which there
at the very center of society I think
two things happened the first is
railways require huge amounts of capital
so in the last half of the 1840s for
example there were literally hundreds of
railway acts going through the British
Parliament each of them costing their
promoters hundreds of hundreds of pounds
secondly there is the idea that
companies should be should should should
should should should be easy to create
this is something that's advocated by
liberal opinion one of the leading
advocates of the idea of making
companies Easy's correct was my own
magazine The Economist which campaigned
vigorously on this front and I think as
a result of this by the 1860s company
creation becomes automatic you just have
to post an address get seven people to
sign on with the idea of a company and
call yourself limited set unit set
people know that their liability is
limited
and what is the result of all this
freedom it's actually chaos and disaster
at first about there are thousands of
companies set up in the net in the in
the decade after the 1862 Act many of
these companies are set up by charlatans
about a third of them go out of business
very very rapidly we've just talked
about Dom Ben's son in 1875 trollope
publishes what is perhaps still the
greatest novel about a company the way
we live now and that's all about
essentially a share as share sharking
scheme and everybody that the company
that that is set up is supposed to
create a railroad build a railroad
between Mexico and the United States but
everybody on the board of the company is
basically indolent aristocrats corrupt
politicians and they're all given to
believe in trollope swerd that where
they're gonna get their money from is
not the creation of a railroad but from
the manufacture of shares so 125 years
before Enron you have the company being
used to Paris nefarious ends
nevertheless the overall effect of this
new organizational form is dramatic you
have companies spreading around the
world you have companies increasing
productivity and you have Rutherford
Hayes saying for example in 1875 this is
a nation this is a government of the
people by the people and for the people
no longer it's a government off of the
company by the company and for the
company
I think the modern history of the
corporation the corporation after
Rutherford Hayes actually comes in two
parts the first half is from about 1870
to 1970 the second half is from 1970 to
the present in the first half you're in
the era of big companies of hierarchical
organizations of company man of company
towns are bundling lots of economic
activity together in a single
organization in the second half that one
that that bundling I think is
essentially unbundled I think the thing
that really makes the difference is the
creation of the modern railroad and that
changes the logic of companies so it
becomes easier and cheaper to bundle
things together and in the in the from
the 1870s onwards you have the rise of
organizations for example like Richard
Sears is that Sears & Roebuck
which creates a huge catalog based we
in business in Chicago you have the
creation of Andrew Carnegie's steel
company introducing mass production to
steel Henry Ford introducing mass
production to cars David Duke into
cigarettes the object of all of these
people is to own as much of the
production process as possible so for
example Henry Ford even owned the Sheep
owned the land on which grazed the sheep
whose wool went into the manufacture of
the seats of his cars and if you didn't
actually own everything your objective
was to buy everything so in the early
20th century you see gigantic museum
mega-mergers the creation of US Steel is
the most astonishing of that when US
Steel was created in the early 20th
century it produced two-thirds of all
the steel produced in the United States
and its value was equivalent to two
thirds of all the money been in
circulation in the United States these
were gigantic organizations these
gigantic organizations create the modern
city they create in reaction against
them the modern trade union they create
the antitrust law and they also create a
new social social person really which is
company man I think that the founders
the entrepreneurs who created these
great organizations took one look at
their children and thought we can't
possibly have them running the company
so they decided to bring in a new class
of professional managers and so
companies become run essentially by
professional teams of workers Thomas
Watson for example one of the greatest
architect of call company man probably
deliberately sets creates IBM set it up
in a small town in New York
Endicott the better to control
everything in his environment and he he
creates a sort of basically a collection
of clones IBM men wear white white
shirts dark suits red ties they refrain
from strong strong drink they sing the
company's song they go and watch the
performance of the great IBM symphony
which I'm sure you've all heard it's a
it's a total community that's being
created there now you can say all sorts
of things against this sort of total
community and many people did from
sociologists speculating about there
that the deficiencies of organization
man to that wonderful scene in in Dustin
Hoffman Hoffman in the Graduate when he
he looks at the future in plastics and
and and and he's revolted by it but this
did create a very well ordered a very
stable society if JP Morgan who died in
1913 had he had he survived and looked
at the world in 1970 would have
recognized most of the American
companies that with it would they were
there you have basically a norm where
companies have very close relationships
with governments the idea that what's
good for General Motors is good further
for the United States you almost have a
system of stakeholder capitalism and
Galbraith I think it's not entirely
wrong when he says in the nineteen
sixties you have a small collection of
car companies a small collection of
steel companies that are essentially
planning the economy for stability they
regard stability is more important from
the 1970s onwards however all this goes
horribly wrong
in 1973 C has proudly unveiled the
world's tallest building this was
supposed to be a bit of local
one-upmanship against the retailer
Montgomery Ward but it was also a
proclamation of confidence in the power
of American capitalism and I think this
proclamation of confidence proof both
eminently justified and absolutely wrong
it was eminently justified in the sense
that the coop the American style company
was just about to go and conquer the
rest of the world it was about to start
operating in places like Russia and
China where it had never operated before
but what was wrong about it was the idea
that it would be a company like Sears an
integrated hierarchical big company that
would go on to dominate the rest of the
world this wasn't what happened I think
what you have from the mid 70s on which
is a huge increase in turbulence and a
huge shift away from big companies to
small companies the average size of
companies begins to go down so if you
look in about 1970 about 36% of the
American economy is dominated by big
industrial companies now it's about 17%
hierarchy becomes something that people
no longer want very much they want
companies to be flat and flexible so you
have a new flash and for things like
things like virtual companies companies
that they really own many assets and
there's basically even those big
companies that do survive survive by the
dint of violent internal revolution
the salt that that Jack Welsh
masterminded the general electric so
this is a different world that we've
created here where are we going to go in
the future I think that there are two
fundamental logics here as I've pointed
to all the way through here the economic
logic in the political logic I think the
economic logic is absolutely towards
much smaller companies much more
flexible organizations and of all the
nonsense that the anti-globalization
people speak I think the idea that the
world is going to be run by a small
handful of companies is the single
biggest sort of nonsense however I think
this perception that big companies are
taking charge does matter because
companies and their relationship with
society their relationship with
government matters very much companies
may not have to go hand in hand anymore
as they did as they did every foot as
these india company did every 25 years
to get a renewed charter but they do in
some sense rely on a franchise from
society and their perception they're too
big and too out of control I think
matters society is imposing all sorts of
regulations on companies on the one hand
they claim that their deregulating and
privatizing but on the other hand the
burden of affirmative action laws health
and safety laws and all sorts of other
laws is getting ever bigger and I think
there's a sense that many companies many
governments want to get social policy on
the cheap by using companies as the
medium for debt for delivering that
social policy and that worries me for
two reasons the first is that companies
are actually very very fragile things
the corporate sector as a whole has
never been bigger and more vibrant but
companies as individual organizations
have never been more fragile and I don't
I don't think there'll be many
organizations around today that last for
250 years of the East India Company the
second is I think that this is based on
a misconception of what companies are
good at what companies are actually good
at is creating products which make
people's lives better and easier so the
the robber barons may have been terrible
people they may have done terrible
things but they bought the luxuries of
the elite into the into the hands of the
masses look what Henry Ford did with the
motorcar so I think what we have to
acknowledge is that what companies do
best is to produce innovations to
produce new products rather than to
provide so
for services and I think companies have
done many many terrible things in it
throughout history they have despoiled
the Belgian Congo they've invented
horrible phrases like total quality
management but I think we have to
acknowledge two things the first is that
they've changed the world over whelming
for the better not for the worst and the
second is that over time they've got
more ethical more moral less less
corrupt so I think that the organisation
that Gilbert and Sullivan sang the
praises of in utopia limited needs at
least a round of applause what is
achieved up to this moment thank you
thank you very much Adrian our commenter
today is Daniel Yergin who travels
apparently effortlessly between the
worlds of international business and
book writing and his world renowned in
both he is chairman of Cambridge Energy
Research Associates an international
consulting and advisory firm he is the
Pulitzer Prize winning author of the
prize the epic quest for oil money and
power and with Joseph Stanislav he is
the author of the commanding Heights
the battle between government and the
marketplace that is remaking the modern
world
another of the three best books on
globalization written by people on this
stage also transformed into a
magnificent PBS series the commanding
Heights which you can get on VHS or DVD
and which is also being rebroadcast on
PBS
it's a six-part series commencing on May
15th so if you haven't had the pleasure
of watching that series I advise you to
tune in or buy it for your library and
now dan Jurgen
thank you very much brink and I'm really
very pleased to be here really for two
reasons
nice legs
can you hear now try not to fiddle with
it as I said I'm very pleased because
Cato's contribution to this whole range
of issues and thinking and its
originality and also because how much I
enjoyed the company I guess some people
pick it up think it's a book about the
CIA but we'll learn otherwise it's a
it's a wonderful book it's a very
original indeed one of the things that
Adrian mentioned the notion that
companies are getting smaller not bigger
would certainly seem to be
counterintuitive from what most think
and it's a very witty book it takes
something that everybody takes for
granted and sheds light and gives us a
way to think about it we all will learn
a lot from it I don't know how many of
you had a chance to look at it outside
but and at the photograph on the cover
and I just thought we might ask who do
you have know what is the photograph of
right right I think and do look at it
you'll certainly sees it it will be meat
for the anti-globalization I come at
this from really - I read it really in
manuscript from two perspectives one is
somebody who writes on the subject and
to somebody who without quite realizing
what I did started a company we have 220
employees around the world and it's one
of those small companies but you learn a
lot in the process so as I read the book
I was reading it with both of those
dimensions in mind it's certainly timely
and it reminds us again of how history
the echoes are so strong I had forgotten
about the Gilbert & Sullivan operetta
about the island of utopia but as you
were you were talking about it Adria and
I was remembering the op-ed piece in The
New York Times a couple of years ago
during the hot heat of the stock market
when somebody was planning to do an IPO
of his entire family and I thought he'd
probably never heard of utopia but of
course it is that shows how these things
come around again I think the book is
more timely now in a way than it would
have been a couple of years ago because
of where we are
remember the new economy it has come and
gone it was gonna be here forever and
we're back sort of an old economy when I
was at Davos this past winter I heard a
very eminent writer on International
Economics tell a group of people from
the oil industry that the oil industry
was the most important industry in the
world and I thought two or three years
ago that would never have been said in
fact it was that industry was finished
so we are in a different era and we've
gone from a period when of course
companies were really hot news exciting
seemed that that's all people talked
about what's happening there 401ks
corporate profits whether a company
exceeded or missed its profit
projections for a quarter by a penny or
so was enough to induce hysteria on the
new show and CEOs were celebrated as
merchant princes who were all knowing
about the world it was a be all in the
end all and all of that has passed we're
in a different period where in fact
there are serious questions about how
markets and capitalism work
disillusionment you can see in many
parts of the world you see it in the way
people are voting in Latin America if
you were a European investor who had
been caught up in the spirit of
discussion about the power and the
significance of anglo-saxon share hold
or values and put a lot of your
retirements into Vivendi or Deutsche
Telekom you would be like some of those
characters in the trollope novel
questioning how markets work and I think
we're still yet to see the impact in the
United States of
what has happened to the equity markets
and what that says about capitalism in
terms of people's retirement I know many
people have stopped opening their 401k
envelopes and that is gonna be part of
the disillusionment as as it hits and of
course there's a stock market and then
there's a market system and many people
tend to conflate them so there are we're
coming out of a period when there are we
hear the term excesses out there just a
couple that I would want to point to one
is the cult of quarterly profits the
notion that markets can go up so much
and the incredible pressure that creates
and the notion that markets would go up
every year by 20 or 30 percent secondly
I think there is a question and as one
reads about some of the severance
agreements of corporate CEOs about a
system that the system in created
circumstances for entrepreneurial
profits going to corporate managers and
that's something that will be continued
to be discussed
I myself have thought that in this whole
debate about double taxation of
dividends a point that has been very
much left out of the discussion hasn't
gotten much attention is that surely
eliminating double taxation of dividends
is one of the most effective things that
can be done to address the issues of
corporate governance in many ways more
effective than a host of new regulations
simply getting the decision rules to to
be clear let me turn to globalization
and that part of the subject when we
were doing commanding heights we wanted
to get beyond globalization so he came
up with this word called globality
and bill Safire in a column that he
wrote said it was okay for us to use it
and we thought of globality being the
world after globalization the 24-hour
interconnected hyper active work network
and sleep-deprived world and it sort of
was you know new economy around the
world well we tried but we didn't make
it so we're back to using the word
globalization and I have found myself
continually wondering what is it about
rather abstract five syllable word that
appears to have been invented in the
mid-1980s what about it is that that
gets people so upset and of course when
you look at it you realize it becomes I
think very much a shorthand as you're
saying for being against corporate
capitalism it's sort of Marxism without
Marx and it's a way it becomes an
umbrella for specific issues that
concern people that they want to focus
focus on and yet well if you bring it
down to world to earth all you're
talking about is a a world that is
getting more tied together more openness
one of my favorite statistics we came
across in the commanding heights was the
number of overseas phone calls for the
United States at the end twenty years
ago was like 200 million a year by the
end of the 1990s it was five billion is
this bad is this good or is it just an
example of the combination of technology
of markets being tied together economic
process and the benefits that come from
it the argument is made that states are
disappearing and if you just look at the
numbers and see that modern industrial
states take roughly 30 to 50 percent of
country's GDP that seems to me pretty
clearly not a disappearing act
the other thing that I think came
through very clearly to me and it's
something when we were working the
commanding heights more than the TV
shows in the book and it's the subject
that brink spends his time on is the
power of trade economists and most
stripes would agree that one thing they
can agree on is a trade is generally a
good thing it raises standards of living
but I think in the public arena it's
really something that's not very well
understood or accepted and yet you ask
the question if you want to take the
issue of global poverty if you want to
say that that's a great test for
globalization then it leads you back to
trade my and I struggle with this and
four decades ago the poorest continent
in the world was Asia Singapore was so
poor that people thought it wouldn't
make it as a country now it has a per
capita income that's higher than Britons
and they did it in about thirty five
years as opposed to two hundred years
well it's by making a bet
being part of the global economy and I
think in this debate you can't really
address the issues of global poverty
without addressing the issues of a more
open trading world well some of the
issues for the future I was struck when
we were as one must do for public
television shows go out and raise funds
from foundations and one foundation we
thought was about to make a grant and
support us and then they I was just
rereading the letter told us they
couldn't support a series that that
seemed to talk about a system and
celebrate unbridled market forces and I
thought give us a break what are they
talking about and it's sort of like the
character of the of the us that you
found in Europe and other places where
people think that somehow this is 19th
century Wild West capitalism when of
course what the United States is is a
pretty highly regulated welfare state
does a lot of its regulation through
litigation and indeed we could have a
discussion about how increasingly
regulated it becomes and certainly
within that if you look at companies and
compare them to where they were 20 or 30
years ago I think by many of the
measures in Adrienne's book you'll see
they're much much more regulated as
entities than they used to be a second
question that follows from that is this
world of sarbanes-oxley that we're in
which some would say is the biggest wave
of corporate governance regulation since
the Great Depression and there's a big
positive here you compare it to Japan
where they've not been able to deal with
these issues now for over a decade and
it shows the responsiveness and the
vitality of our system but I think I've
been surprised by the lack of attention
and helping to move this beyond it
really rather more quickly than might
have been expected but I find the
failure the relative lack of attention
to the law of unintended consequences
and all the things that have been set in
motion by it and you talk to people
involved in corporate governance and
there's a lot that's happened that that
that wasn't anticipated or expected I
think an issue that Adrian and his
co-author discussed is is of course core
or social responsibility and that's
clearly a very big question at
shareholders versus stakeholders and
it's kind of a constant pressure and I
think the book actually gives us context
for thinking about it I also think there
are a couple of key aspects of the
sovereignty question going back to your
period Adrian of the 1970s and ITT the
church hearings the whole message was
companies thou shalt not get involved in
the domestic affairs of sovereign states
well in a way that's now turned around
and companies are being told yes indeed
you've got to get involved in this
affairs of sovereign states on a whole
range of issues it's a very complex
question and it's one as given our
nature of litigation is going to alien
tort law and so forth it's going to
become a more complex issue and a very
difficult one for companies to deal with
and to find the right footing
I think another point that I would make
goes back to somebody who's quite
important I know inspiration for this
book ray Vernon and Raymond Vernon who
had been a professor at Harvard somebody
who was very influential on our work and
in his last book he pointed during the
sort of hype of the newly new economy
that where companies as much as critics
of companies were saying government's
didn't matter borders didn't matter with
long experience he had started his
career and enforcement in the SEC in the
1930s he was the one who chronicled and
created the study of multinational
corporations talked about the basic
clash between an economic system of a
global marketplace with companies and a
political system of sovereign states and
the inevitable clashes that will occur
and as we look at some of the dismal
results of investment of one kind or
another around the world we see the
truth of that and that that's going to
continue the last point I'd like to end
on adrian is with your friend Ishtar
from four thousand years ago and you
didn't pick up on that segue how can I
resist doing that there he was in Sumer
launching a venture capital fund
and of course the focus is on the Middle
East today in Iraq today and asking
what's going to happen is it going to be
a country on welfare for many years with
deep political social much violence or
will it evolve and it's very interesting
if any of you read the UN Development
Programme study on forgot the exact
title Arab Social Development in the
Middle East something like that which
really questioned about how the Middle
East has not been part of this process
of global integration of Trade and
connection partly you can say it's I
mean when they say its culture you could
say it's the resource curse which comes
from oil and so forth but there is a
question about how openness may lead in
surprising ways in Iraq in the region
and a point that I think that you would
make Adrian the importance of companies
their key point in creating civil
societies in breaking the monopoly of
the state and perhaps the picture might
end up looking different than some think
if we go back to that creating
circumstances that would allow Adam
Smith's observation about the propensity
to truck barter and exchange one thing
for another
and do it in a civil society with law in
Iraq and other countries perhaps we
would see more positive benefits than
some might expect so thank you very much
thank you Dan now like to open the floor
up for a few questions raise your hand
I'll recognize you
someone will come around with a mic wait
for the mic please then give your name
and a brief question address to one or
both of the speakers yeah this is a
question for Adrian in the early part of
your talk you talked about historic
opposition by libertarians to limited
liability corporations this is in that
vein do you see any meaningful
difference between a limited liability
corporation that comes about because of
contract Arian pronouncements to both
creditors and customers that says
remember that while you're dealing with
us we do not fact accept liability in a
broad sense versus limited liability
corporations which are legal devices as
they are today and then if you're if
there is a meaningful difference between
the two what's the viability of each
well we know what the viability of the
latter is of course but what's the
viability of the contract Arian legal
liability notion which would probably
more comfortable libertarians well a
little bit about the difference a little
bit more about what you think the
difference is one difference with me on
tort liability right that a purely
contract Arian firm could declare it to
its contractors that that liability for
deaths or for contracts would be limited
by third parties would fall outside of
that yeah that'd be one example but I
mean because libertarians you know
philosophically have always seen that if
limited liability corporations could
arise as a market phenomena through
contract area means there wouldn't be
those objections but because they're so
often a political device is where you
get that so is there any viability of a
limited liability corporation that comes
about contract Arian in its origin well
I think one has to deal with the world
that as it is and then and the simple
truth is that's not the path that we've
gone down that we
we went down a path essentially in which
the government's had an extraordinarily
intrusive role in corporate life up
until up until the mid 19th century that
it reserved the right of limited
liability to those organizations that
were doing the government's will they
were essentially given monopolies to run
railroads or to or to run canals
whatever and the road that was taken was
I think the easiest one that you could
have taken which was simply to move out
of that business of precisely regulating
companies and just just to create the
option of registering seven people
saying that they were going to be
company directors posting the fact that
your liability was limited posting an
address and doing all that sorta stuff
so I think I think it was it's a
compromise but it's a fairly it's a
fairly recognizable and easy compromise
to take now I recognize that all sorts
of libertarians have had problems with
that not least the fact that it means
that the obligations for debts tends to
be imposed on the rest of society rather
than on the people who are engaged in
the business contract but I think on
balance if you look at the way that
these organizations both I think created
a counterweight to the state and I think
this is it was a remarkable thing
there's up until the mid 19th century
essentially corporations have been
extensions of state power from the mid
19th century onwards they're rapidly
turned into constraints on state power
and secondly the way they spread around
the world with such speed and the way
that they do go from being marginal to
economic life to being absolutely
central to economic life in a matter of
30 or 40 years is an extraordinary
testimony to the viability of this of
this compromise that was produced
Phil thank you
Phil Harvey dkt Liberty project mr.
Wooldridge I'm curious as to why
companies began getting smaller in on or
about 1970 as I believe you said whether
you think that's a good thing and
whether you expect it to continue sure I
think that the logic of size is
determined by the whether it makes more
sense economic rata costs of doing
something in-house are bigger or smaller
than the transaction costs of going to
the market and I think really underlying
what's going on is that the transaction
costs of going to the market are
constantly getting lower because of
Technology because it's simply easier to
go to the market to get things done on
the other hand the bureaucratic costs of
doing things internally within a company
are not going down anything like the
like as quickly although they will go
down because of technology so there's an
overwhelming economic pressure for
companies to get smaller and I think
that will that will continue to go on I
think that the the top that the biggest
50 companies in the world have grown
much more slowly than the world economy
as a whole over the last 10 to 20 years
and I think also globalization is
crucial here because I think what
globalization does is exactly the
opposite of what the anti-globalization
people think it does what it does is
make it easier to raise capital make it
easier to buy and use technology and
make it easier to get your stuff to the
market because you no longer need to
have very close relationships with with
with local government officials all you
need to do is to be able to physically
get your stuff to the market and so it
makes that that shifts hugely the
balance of advantage away from
incumbents towards challengers and the
story that always intrigues me here is
the story of Nokia which up until the
early 1980s was basically a Finnish firm
stuck there in a slightly obscure part
of the world apologies to any Finn's
here for saying that and it was
producing wellington boots and paper and
pulp products and the then head
nokia visited Gorbachev and decided god
he had found his ideal market there was
Gorbachev in charge of all these people
who didn't have any lavatory paper here
he was running a paper and pulp company
he could provide them with lavatory
paper he became the laboratory paper
paper making giant of the world he
unfortunately committed suicide and he
was replaced by a man who saw the future
of that company in wireless telephones
and very very rapidly this company that
started out in Finland becomes a mobile
phone making giant so I think it's just
an illustration of the way that
challenges can get even if they're in in
peripheral parts of the world can get
into markets very very rapidly as long
as they have a good idea and and a good
corporate culture they can they can take
over or they can become major major
players in world markets and I think the
overall logic of that of this shift away
from incumbents towards challengers plus
the fact that transaction costs are
going down more rapidly than
bureaucratic costs means that overall in
the long term the logic is for the size
of companies to go down governments and
political pressures complicate that
process but underneath it all I think
we're living in a world of smaller more
fragile and more nimble companies let me
if I can't just challenge you a little
bit on that I mean people will say for
instance in the media business that now
a five billion dollar a year media
company is really too small and it needs
to be part of a 25 or 30 billion dollar
now maybe they won't say that after the
recent troubles of AOL and so forth but
what about kind of a propensity to scale
that that shuts out or makes it
difficult for smaller companies just
because they have such a commanding
position in the marketplace well I mean
I think the answer to that in the media
side of things is is is is blogging I
mean it's it's extraordinary how
influential all these bloggers are who
just single people sitting living rather
lonely existences I sometimes think
their rooms getting up very early or
staying up very very late at night get
going sifting through all this vast
amount of material is there free on the
internet or very very cheap on the
internet and producing these these
blocks in them and I must say I read
blogs in the morning before I read the
New York Times or the world why
why general because these people have
done all the work which I would do if I
was a more assiduous person and maybe
read they've read through the net you
know many many many more newspapers and
I have time to read through and they
picked out the most interesting things
and and I think the bear also sharper in
many ways than the editors of a lot of
the tabloid papers and they pick out
what's interesting and presented in you
know nugget form in fairly short form
and I think it's an example of a perfect
example of the way that technology plus
people who are working for nothing or
very very free can really challenge you
know that the big media organizations
for people's time and attention I should
read just a sentence from the book in
which Adrienne is co-author say we
should admit that through luck absence
of opportunity laziness and especially
the charity of others
we've both remained at the same
organization for most of our working
lives thank God for those bloggers a
quick elaboration on Adrienne's comments
which will then lead to a Cato
promotional announcement and and that is
that that in addition though first of
all I think it's overly simplistic to
think of of corporate size proceeding in
some sort of monolithic trend where all
industries at all times are either
getting bigger or getting smaller you
see within different industries
consolidation and then break ups of
consolidation and break ups out of all
of that you can abstract away big trends
and certainly the big trend in the past
quarter century or so has been towards
smaller corporate size one contributor
to that in addition to communications
technologies that have reduced
transactions costs is the development of
financial markets we are having a book
forum day after tomorrow about a really
splendid book called saving capitalism
from the capitalists about the
development of financial markets and
especially when arms-length open
transparent liquid financial markets
aren't developed it's much easier for
corporations to do allocation of capital
in-house they take their retained
earnings and they figure out new
ventures to go into when you have
as an alternative to that internal
capital allocation arms-length financial
markets to send capital to its highest
value use you tend to see big corporate
empires whether vertically integrated or
conglomerate breaking up and in much of
the financial turmoil of the 70s and 80s
was breaking up a lot of those corporate
empires Roger
yes I'm Roger Palin or the Cato
Institute I want to add rien go back to
that first question on limited liability
because I think that it serves as a
foundation for the critique of the
corporation that is not grounded in good
measure in misunderstanding and even
among libertarians you pointed I have in
mind for example the burly man's thesis
of the 30s or they Nader green and Simon
attack on the giant corporation in the
seventies all of which would it were
rooted in this idea of limited liability
being a grant from the state and
therefore warrants intrusion into
corporate affairs and a greater
regulation including on the net agreed
and Seligman thesis the federal
chartering of corporations the you
pointed to the without saying some
deters the distinction between special
chartering in the early part of the 19th
century and the general chartering that
took place later on in the century which
was really the birth of the modern
corporation without the monopoly grant
now the limited liability issue is not
really a grant from the state lab it is
simply a declaration by the corporation
with respect of contractual situation
that you're dealing with a separation of
management and ownership and you're
going to be you will be able to go only
against the assets of the corporation
not the assets of the shareholders and
nobody is forcing you to contract with
the corporation with respect to that
with respect to the tort side which
break raise there it seems to me we have
always asked the wrong question the
question is not
whether the shareholders liability
should be limited but whether they
should be liable at all after all
they're not the ones who committed the
tort it's the driver or whatever it is
who committed the tort and therefore we
go to such things as theories of
respondeat superior and those theories
as Holmes said have always been easier
to live with them to justify in the
classic justifications from benefit or
from from control simply break down on
real scrutiny and so here too you've got
the ability to sue the actual tort
feasor without going against the
shareholder and it seems to me our
insurance mechanisms to address that so
these critiques of the corporation based
upon limited liability seems to me are
fundamentally misguided I think that's
fascinating and I don't really want to
add anything to that because they you've
expressed my own deeper thoughts which
far better than I could express them
myself I would just add one thing to
that there that if you read dicey on
this subject his big worry is not really
to do with limited liability and and who
bears the burden of corporate failure
his big worry is that the pressure to
create companies is the pressure of
agglomeration of capital and that
companies were essentially instruments
of collectivism which will essentially
drive out of business smaller companies
and they're also instruments of
irresponsibility because of this the
agency problem the fact that managers
wouldn't have the same anxious vigilance
in running a company that owner
entrepreneurs would do so he just
thought that that they would lead to to
scale and size and indeed it was you
know their desire for large amounts of
money from the railway industry and
others that did lead to pressure for
companies and at the same time something
like Karl Marx is really welcoming the
creation of companies because he thought
he thought that eventually they would
lead to do to collectivism